[Music]
welcome to day three of next I am so
excited to see so many people here days
wanted to have an action-packed I don't
know about you but I drank probably
about a pot of coffee this morning
so I am rip-roarin or ready to go my
name is Jeff Johnson I'm a software
engineer on the gke team in Seattle and
I'm Tina Jiang I'm a site reliability
engineer for gke based in London so you
were gonna talk to you about delivering
high availability clusters on gke this
talk isn't going to go into a lot of
details about what kubernetes is we're
sort of expecting you to bring some of
that experience in maybe you've used
chiku brands and gke maybe you know
otherwise but what we want to do is dive
into some of the details on how we
deploy kubernetes how we manage it
Tina's going to talk to you about how
sre keeps clusters healthy and what I
want to do is share some best practices
and taking an application and making it
resilient to zonal failure so let's
start with the Kay if you have been
around GC PNX this week you've probably
heard this word a few hundred times now
so this slide might be a little
irrelevant but kubernetes
is an open source container
orchestration framework originally built
by Google and now in the open source
community
it is based off our experience running
containers at scale with org kubernetes
can run on any infrastructure it can run
in the cloud is a hosted offering it
could run on Prem but the important
thing to know for today's talk is that
kubernetes is all about managing
applications not infrastructure gke is
of course google kubernetes engine it's
a mature product that has been generally
available for three years now although
to be honest I think it's three years on
like a month but to the significant
digit I think that's pretty good if
you're interested in following gke our
updates tips and tricks
I recommend checking out the Google
cloud platform blog so with a little bit
of that product background key is going
to talk to you more about GCP
thanks Jeff hmm so let's say you've
decided that GK is the right solution
for your workloads next key decision
that will influence the reliability and
availability of your application is how
you deploy your GK cluster across GCP
locations so at the moment you have a
choice of 17 regions and 52 zones and
these are expanding all the time so
regions are independent geographic areas
or loosely speaking a campus of data
centers that consist of zones and ozone
is a deployment area for cloud platform
resources within a region so between
zones of the same region you have
high-bandwidth low-latency network
connections that you can typically
typically expect of less than the
millisecond in the 95th percentile and
from an availability point of view zones
should be considered a single point of
failure words of failure domain within a
region so let's take a look at how that
works in gke so the most basic
deployment is what we call a zonal
cluster deployment like the one pictured
here where you have a single master
along with nodes all in the same zone
and when you run a coop Nettie's cluster
on gke we host the master VM in our own
Google project and you create worker
nodes in your projects so in this mode
kubernetes will mitigate against
individual machine failures but in the
event of a zonal failure such as an
asteroid striking a data center the
entire cluster will go down so in order
to deploy fault tolerant applications
with high availability you should deploy
your applications across multiple zones
in a region in order to help protect
against this single point of failure and
that's what we call a multi zonal no
deployment so in this configuration gke
will distribute your worker nodes across
multiple zones within the same region
you have to have at least one note in
the same zone as your master and you
cannot deploy notes in a completely
separate region and if you're using
cluster autoscaler and your cluster
contains note pools that have the same
instance type cluster autoscaler will
try to keep those node pool sizes
balanced for you when it's scaling up in
order to prevent against uneven
distribution of note pool sizes across
multiple zones so this means that an
asteroid strike in a single zone won't
take down your entire cluster and Jeff
is going to describe those failure modes
in more detail so let's look at a
typical application deployed on gke so
if we look at this diagram we have that
hosted master node in u.s. central one F
and that's in a Google managed project
so it's actually a bit opaque to you as
a user of gke but it's important to know
what's there and we have our nodes
across three zones so each one of those
green boxes maps to a GCE VM these
little yellow checkered boxes above
that's representing your application
workload so in this case we have a
deployment we have asking for three
replicas of that deployment and
kubernetes has chosen to spread them
across these zones so what happens when
that asteroid strikes so we've lost our
VMs they are offline cannot be reached
but we've maintained the other set of
machines the rest the other two failure
domains there are happy and healthy so
they're able to continue to serve
traffic instances that are running on
those machines are going to be
unaffected but the kubernetes master is
regularly pooling and looking at the
state of the world and will make the
decision to schedule a new pot you know
it expects three it sees two so it'll
create a second so in that case we get
our application back everything is happy
but you know this is the lucky case
right we were fortunate that the zone
that went down the zone that we had an
issue with happened to not be the zone
or master node is in so what happens if
that master node goes down
so in this case we still have those
running workloads they still are
remaining on those healthy nodes and
kubernetes is designed to sit in this as
sort of a steady state the nodes won't
evict the workloads they're only waiting
to be told what to do but they don't
have anything new to do so they'll sort
of remain in that mode traffic can
continue to enter the the cluster so if
you're using the global load balancer
it's doing health checks on those down
nodes and won't route traffic to them
however where you will experience a
problem is when you have internal
services so if you have an internal
kubernetes service that is in that
downed node over there that Don zone the
internal services may still try to route
to that machine and that's because the
control plane in the master node are
responsible for registering the
endpoints that tell the services where
to go when I want to connect a Redis it
tells me okay this is a hop that you can
go to that's available and without the
control plane up I'm gonna have a stale
set of routes so we see how a single
node is can be problematic and can
result in sort of this state patinas
going to talk to you about how we want
to solve some of that in order to
eliminate the single point of failure
that Jeff just described you can use a
gke regional cluster which is a product
that became generally available in June
and with a regional cluster you get a
multi master set up where there are
three masters in three different zones
within a GCP region so we have a load
balancer that's sitting in front of
these masters and that serves as the
endpoint that's used to communicate with
the control plane and by having three
masters behind your GK you cluster we
help to eliminate downtime when montt
work when when one master becomes
unavailable either because it's become
into an unhealthy State or because it's
being upgraded so when we perform
upgrades of the master we upgrade one at
a time so you don't get the downtime
that you would experience with a zone or
cluster deployment
and then when it comes to the nodes you
could still choose to have all of your
nodes singly home within one region so
it within one's own or you can use the
multi zonal deployment that's shown here
which works much the same as before but
of course ultimately if you have a multi
master setup and a multi zonal
deployment that doesn't automatically
mean that your application is high
availability so that begs the question
what does high availability mean I think
when we talk high availability a lot of
times we jump towards solutions we
talked about putting load balancers and
things like that failover
but simply put high availability means
meeting some high sll and practice that
some number of nines that meets your
business needs and really there's many
ways to achieve AJ you could have for
instance an H a or excuse me a highly
available network connection that you
buy from an isp because they gave you a
dedicated circuit that has an extremely
high SL L or you could buy internet from
a couple of providers and perform
failover between them when you're
designing your application to meet a
high SLO it's important that you
understand all the pieces that make up
that application and can understand
where all the failures can happen one
way to split that up and I think this
works well for a lot of applications but
we'll say in the context of kubernetes
is to break it up into these four layers
the control plane the networking the
application and the persistence
underneath all that we saw how a single
zone cluster on gke could go down with a
zone and the failures that can happen so
it's clearly not a high availability
solution but as cluster administrator's
it's our responsibility to ensure that
our cluster our control plane is running
in a way that supports that failover
Tina's going to dive into some of those
pieces of the control plane into the
kubernetes internals to talk about how
we manage that okay so taking a closer
look at what's happening with the
opponents on the masses when you're
running a GK regional cluster so here
we're going to show you how they
interact with each other in order to
deliver this high availability control
plane so to start off when it comes to
the API server these all work in active
active mode so all the API servers are
actively doing the work that's being
assigned to them by the load balancer
and this is possible because the API
server is a stateless component so it
doesn't matter which individual API
server is receiving the request but they
only talk to their local Etsy DS but
when it comes to Etsy D things are a
little bit more complex so a group of
Etsy D instances together is called an
Etsy D cluster and because Etsy D is a
distributed key-value store that's
backed by a database there needs to be
leader election with a strict majority
in order for rights to the database to
succeed and you might ask why here there
are actually two at C D clusters and
this is because there is a quartet CD
that has the kind of main kubernetes
objects that influence the functionality
and operations of the cluster that's at
C D 0 and then there's a separate at C D
1 cluster that's used just for storing
kubernetes events so these events
objects are providing an insight into
what's happening inside the cluster such
as a pod rescheduling or a pod
eviction but they're not fundamental to
the functioning of the cluster and you
can imagine that they'd probably be
quite high in number so we keep them in
a separate at CD cluster for that reason
and I once spent a little bit of time
delving into why we have three masters
for regional clusters and not two or
four and this is all related to how at
CD reaches quorum in order to write to
the to write to the database so for
writes to succeed you need a strict
majority so ie two out of three masters
much must reach agreement
and with three masters that means you
can tolerate the failure of one master
because the remaining two healthy
instances are still able to reach quorum
so it guarantees that they'll still be a
majority of the cluster that can
continue to operate however if we only
had two masters you would still need
both members to be healthy to reach the
strict majority so you wouldn't have any
fell over in that case so it's worth
noting that actually during the period
in which a master is being upgraded or
one master is unavailable your cluster
remains we across the control plane
remains available but technically
speaking at that point in time it's no
longer a high availability control plane
because if there was meteor strike on
one of the two remaining masters rights
to the database with no longer succeed
so you can see from this example that
having an odd cluster size doesn't
change the number needed to reach a
majority but you gain extra failure
tolerance by adding the extra member so
you always want to run a net Siddhi
cluster with an odd number of members so
by running a net Siddhi cluster of size
three this means that our control plane
is tolerant to the failure of one
machine and of course it makes sense to
spread these across different locations
so for the other control plane
components the controller manager the
scheduler as well as the cluster
autoscaler these all have their own
elections but they operate in active
passive mode so only the leader is doing
any work and it talks directly to its
local API server on the same master
there's also an add-on manager leader
election and this just follows the
elected controller manager leader so
that's one piece of the overall pie
right having a highly reliable control
panel there's control plant panel is
nice too but the network is also a key
piece of that when we talk about high
availability and failover that often
needs load balancing but when you're
thinking about load balancing it's
important that that piece isn't its own
single point of failure load
bouncing on GCP is not like a
traditional H a proxy machine you know
back maybe by DNS round-robin or
something like that
gku uses network load balancing a
product that's available for you to use
on GCE that load balancing is backed by
technology called maglev maglev there's
a lot of excellent papers out there that
go into great detail but essentially it
is a non proxying load balancer that's
part of our software-defined network and
it's the same technology backing load
balancing across lots of products in
Google so what this diagram represents
are some of the fiber connections
between GCPs data centers so Google lays
a lot of a lot of its own cable across
the sea and we run our network at a
pretty low utilization what that all it
gives us is the ability to do failover
so let's say you know Godzilla pops out
somewhere in the middle there and takes
one or two cables down we have Headroom
in the other connections to send the
data so we're ready for to do those
sorts of failover a sort of redundancy
and Headroom is critical to have network
reliability okay so we've talked a
little bit about how the control plane
operates in a high availability scenario
let's delve into a bit of what gke is
doing for you under the hood when we
create a regional cluster and by
extension how you might go about
bootstrapping a high availability
cluster yourself because after all
kubernetes is an open source project and
many of our users actually well many of
our kubernetes users might choose to run
their own high availability cluster
directly on Google compute engine or on
pram in a data center so kubernetes the
hard way by Kelsey Hightower does
outline the steps of what you would need
to do to roll your own high availability
solution we're not going to go into all
of that today but there's also the
cluster lifecycle special interest group
in the open source project that have
developed a cube ADM tool that helps a
lot with the boot
strapping of the control plane however
even with those fantastic resources you
still have to do a lot of the
higher-level setup and configuration
importantly you'd still need to
bootstrap your own high availability
etsy D cluster and the steps are again
pretty well documented by core OS who
founded the Etsy D projects but they're
still fairly involved and they include
setting up additional firewall rules and
SSL certificates between the sed servers
for communication as well as setting up
some sort of high availability proxy in
front and vital system pods such as cube
DNS you'd also need to set those up to
use auto scaling and ante affinity rules
to be distributed across multiple nodes
and Jeff is going to describe that a
little bit later on but once you have
everything initialized managing EDD
clusters can be a significant complexity
overhead in itself and I think we in the
SRE team and many others in the
kubernetes open-source community have
found this out the hard way so
historically we've run zonal gke
clusters so just with one at CD replicas
we've had issues due to Etsy D crash
looping after a restart due to bug in
right ahead log reading there's also a
bug in the version of Etsy D we were
using where the database size would
become increasingly bloated and D
fragmented and with regional clusters we
have the added complexity of of leader
election so we had some regional
specific Etsy debugs where the Etsy d1
events were not garbage collected
properly and where you could have an
Etsy D member lagging behind in database
snapshots and so not being fully caught
up with the rest of the cluster so what
we also found was that the steps
involved in fixing an Etsy D replica
that's part of a three-member cluster is
also a lot more involved than just
fixing one @cd replica EDD is also
extremely sensitive to disk i/o so in
the open-source version of this talk we
always recommend to not provision the
resources too conservatively because
when at CD becomes overloaded you really
need that disk capacity but don't just
take our word for it as I mentioned
there's a lot of cute con talks on this
topic from us and also other people
managing their own clusters but with gke
the good news is the the cluster
creation process happens behind the
scenes at a click of a button and once
your cluster is up and running your
friendly SRE team are responsible for
managing the control playing components
on your behalf so you have a little bit
of background on the top two layers of
the stock what you get from using gke
let's talk about the next - let's talk
about your application and the
persistence a reliable kubernetes
cluster is a table stake for high
availability but it's not a silver
bullet as an application developer it's
your responsibility to ensure that your
application is deployed in a way that's
ready to handle failure your persistence
should be resilient to single zone
failure so on GC if our GK or GCE if
you're using persistent disks that means
using a regional disk and picking two
zones to do replication across I'll show
you how to do that in a bit and if
you're using other data services within
GC p such as cloud sequel you to make
sure that they're configured in a highly
available configuration and support
failover your application should be
running in a mode that is ready for
failure so for instance just like the
kubernetes api server if you're running
in an active active mode that means that
any one of your instances are ready to
handle traffic at any time this is a
excellent pattern for stateless
applications and they're generally very
easy to just turn the replica knob up
but it doesn't work for a lot of other
applications especially stateful
applications so there are other patterns
such as active
passive you can utilize in an active
passive mode much like our controller
manager you've got one instance that is
doing all the work and a few that are
sort of sitting idly by reading ready to
be summoned that requires a lot more
orchestration and I'll show you how you
can sort of achieve a little bit of that
with a little bit of downtime
by using kubernetes so with all of that
background in a week of hearing the word
kubernetes let's jump into a demo where
we actually make some stuff fail so if
you've ever seen a kubernetes demo no
doubt you've seen the guest book the
guest book is a bit of a toy app but it
actually represents a lot of a common
pattern seen in just about every
application so if you haven't seen the
guest book the guest book is like a
ledger you can write a message well
they've got something saved there and it
is persisted through refresh is good
it's working but to really understand
what's going on on apply this to your
application we need to look at the
services that make up the application
first I will of course reconnect to my
GCE VM so we can show you if you're
interested in looking at the guest book
the guest book is in the kubernetes repo
the main kubernetes repo under examples
and what I did was I took the yeah Mille
that's deploying it today and I made a
few tweaks to support failover so let's
look at how it's deployed first
so this is a bit of an eye chart here so
I apologize for that but I'll sort of
walk you through the the groups here the
top three nodes the top three pods are
the front end that's a server list web
application in a docker container it
happens to be a PHP application
alright I'm throwing no shade on that
that was my first language besides
English and if you look that far right
column in the notes section those are
across two separate nodes and the three
instances are cost to separate nodes
those two separate nodes are deployed to
different zones that's down here so we
have one of those nodes in central 1c
and one in central 1f the next set of
pods here is the Redis follower the
rightest follower is a read-only copy of
the database so the persistence doesn't
really matter it will get in sync with
the leader when we ask it when we query
for it so whenever we do renders of the
guestbook but every two views we're
gonna ask those databases what what the
state of the world is but when we need
to do writes we're going to talk to
Redis leader notice leader is the center
of truth and that means that it's
persistence is really important if a
zone went down and we couldn't get the
disk back from that zone well
essentially our application is in a
state where it's not useful but a bonus
that we get by having those read-only
replicas running on separate nodes as
well is that if one of those goes down
in the meantime while the leader is
being rescheduled we still have a full
copy of our database we can still do
reads we may just have to wait a little
bit to do commits so let's take this
thing down I want to make sure we take
down the one with a red is follower so
let's do a little watch
and that followers on DG zero zero of
course our leader and that is central
one seat okay
so fortunately for you I do not have the
ability to actually shut down a GCE zone
I could see where that would be a
concern as a customer but what I do have
is the kubernetes api and what the API
lets me do is that lets me mark a note
is unscheduled and then immediately
evict all the workloads off of that if
you're playing along at home you can run
these same commands their drain is the
one you want to start a victim the
workloads and or you could do a g-cloud
compute instance delete the reason why
I'm just affecting them right here is
that it does take a little bit of time
for that note to come down and then
kubernetes to go all right it's time to
reschedule that work and that's because
it's also designed for a failure it's
gonna have some loops before it takes
action but we're in a demo we want to
see action fast and while I blabbed over
that whole thing we can see the Redis
leader was rescheduled it's been running
now for thirty-eight seconds some of our
other pods are have been rescheduled and
the ones that were running on that
healthy note that we didn't mess with
had been running for three hours when I
woke up this morning and let's hope this
thing still works okay that's a good
sign
so this looks like a toy this is simple
but what we've actually done here is
we've taken down a machine in his zone
let's let's focus on the Redis the Redis
leader we took it down on his own it had
an attached disk that disk contained the
truth of our application we moved it to
a new machine in a different zone that
was happy we reattached that disk and it
came up you know in a span of a short
period of time throughout that time our
application would have been accessible
we had been able to ingress into our
cluster while that Redis leader was
being rescheduled we wouldn't been able
to make rights but we can still keep our
page up and healthy and that's a
trade-off that you need to make when
you're considering your application
deployment this by the way isn't what
you'll get if you deploy the guestbook
if you go to kubernetes examples
guestbook that's not what you'll get out
of the box let's look at some of the
changes I'm
to make that work so let's look at the
front end so the front end as I
mentioned is a stateless application it
has a this is sorry the amel section of
the talk so might be extra hard to see
oh yeah
doesn't get a lot bigger than that so it
is a kubernetes deployment with three
replicas and that's where you say I got
a bunch of pods run three copies of it
out of the box kubernetes doesn't make
any scheduling guarantees about where
those go so it could just as well stick
all those replicas on the same node if
you're relying on a high replica count
to handle failover that's really not
going to cut it that's just one piece of
the puzzle what you need to be what you
can do though is you can hint at
kubernetes you can tell it what you want
and if we look at the bottom the way
i've done that is using pod anti
affinity pod anti affinity either tells
or hints at the scheduler to schedule
your pods in some way so if you look at
if you dive down the tree a little bit
here we've specified the same metadata
the same app selector app guestbook to
your front end and we specified this
failure domain key that being this zone
key so this is where you are starting to
think about what you want your
application to be resilient to this
could also be a machine and this will
tell kubernetes okay if a pod is already
scheduled on this zone or this machine
try not to schedule another one there
the Redis follower is deployed in the
same way I'm not retaining its
persistence across because it is able to
catch itself up to speed we could try
doing that and it should work but if you
don't need to make it that complex
don't let your testing and let your
evaluation of the reliability inform
those sort of decisions one thing I want
to point out though is that we've used
prefer schedule you can tell kubernetes
absolutely do not schedule this note if
it's on those if it meets these
conditions but what would happen in that
failure scenario is when we lost a zone
sure we'll move over the work that needs
can be moved over those like Singleton's
but we're not going to reschedule the
nodes that you'd expect we're not going
to say okay well let's shift all these
leaders over here to this healthy zone
so we won't actually be able to serve
the same capacity that we could before
it's important to be aware of this as
you're planning your deployment the most
interesting one to show off is the Redis
leader the Redis leaders deployed as a
stateful set and I change that from
being a deployment and what stateful set
allows us to do here is specify a volume
claim template a volume claim template
says okay I need a disk and the disk has
this sort of storage class just a name
just a string that I picked here and
kubernetes will reliably attach this
disk or attempt to attach this disk to
my node and eventually to my pod so the
the volume I'm mounting is Redis data
and it's in the slash data directory of
the container nothing crazy but the
storage class is something that you're
creating in your planning so let's take
a look at how I define this storage
class for the storage class you specify
a name a provisioner so I'm using the
GCE persistent disk and then the
parameters for that provisioner and the
important ones to look at today are the
replication type we're using a regional
PD
and then we're specifying two zones for
that Regional PD to replicate - so
regional PDS allow us to say across
these zones I want to make sure that my
data is always being replicated so if I
do it right here it is always available
in this other zone these zones don't
necessarily need to coincide with your
VMs but for performance it's probably a
good idea and when you think about your
exposure to failure it's probably a good
idea to be aware of that as well
all right so now that we've seen a demo
in action let's sort of review some of
those core concepts and best practices
for your own application back on the
slides thank you so regional clusters
are a piece of the puzzle to handle
zonal failures but they give you a lot
of everyday improvements like zero
downtime upgrades and resizes so
something you should be aware of if you
resize your cluster from one worker note
to a hundred we're gonna resize the
master node backing that in our project
this is a lot more traffic 100 knows
obviously 100 X and in that scenario
because we roll out changes one by one
in a regional cluster you shouldn't see
a lot of downtime and that that should
be a graceful failover as of GA regional
clusters are free so there's a really
concern about cost in terms of having a
bunch of master nodes but node locations
are really something you should be aware
of and a reason to be aware of that is
around crosses onal traffic so if you
have an application that is particularly
latency sensitive that's doing a lot of
interest service communication you might
be used to that one millisecond in the
95th percentile timing that's sort of
latency but it's going to be increased
when it's going across the zone like Tia
mentioned earlier think of it as going
out of one building in the campus and
going to another another concern is cost
of that traffic so when you're running
traffic within your zone you're not
being billed for that but when you cross
the zones there is billing associated
with that so if you're doing something
like pulling down a lot of database
results if you're doing something like
streaming a lot of log data that can add
up and it's something you should be
aware of as you plan your deployment
technologies like sto like a service
mesh can help you to sort of inform
these and plan these out a little bit
better a few things just to be aware of
that are really more edge cases is that
when you spread across multiple zones
you
our opening you're exposing yourself
more to zonal issues the simple fact
that you're in more zones means you know
that you might be in that unlucky
asteroid strike right things like
upgrades create some deletes could be
impacted by that it will certainly take
more time to roll those changes out
because we do those one by one instead
of in one shot so if you have an
environment where you're creating G K
clusters very rapidly you should be
aware of that something like a CI
environment if you're running a big
cluster it's not a guarantee that you
can spin up 500 nodes immediately or a
thousand nodes immediately so you may
run into quota limits for example so
it's important just like your
applications are reserving for capacity
and failure that you also have some node
capacity if that's what you're designing
for and at the moment you can't navigate
excuse me migrate between a zonal
cluster and a regional cluster so it's a
choice you have to make upfront so with
that background Tina is going to talk to
you about how we these clusters healthy
and reliable okay
yes so we've demonstrated how the gke
regional clusters products can make your
gke cluster more reliable so well how
are Google engineers keeping their side
of the bargain to help make the gke
system reliable this is a challenge for
us particularly as the adoption in gke
continues to grow as well as the number
of GCP locations so in the asari team
we're responsible for managing the fleet
of gke hosted masters and making sure
that the kubernetes control plane
components are up and running as well as
managing the upgrade cycle of the
masters and ultimately protecting the
service level objectives to ensure
positive customer experience for our
users so we do this by holding the pager
for the product but we also help to work
with feature launches the release
process and general product designs with
our developer partners as well as other
teams within Google that gke is reliant
on and we have teams in Seattle and
London providing 24
have an on-call coverage and ultimately
the aim of all site reliability
engineering teams is to automate our own
jobs away much in the same vein as the
kubernetes self-healing philosophy so
that the system can detect and heal
itself without manual intervention and
we do this by iterating on pages and
outages to make sure that they don't
happen repeatedly so in order to do this
we need to have good observe ability and
strong insights into the system behavior
so we care both about the gke platform
as well as every single cluster we do
this by gathering metrics on both of
those aspects and visualizing them on
dashboards using an internal Google
version that's been around for years
used by all sre teams but it's pretty
similar to how you might use Prometheus
or graph honor for metric gathering and
visualization in your own clusters and
we also keep an aggregated view of this
so that we can see fleet wide
differences between cloud locations and
different kubernetes versions and
finally we have some probers running
outside of Google cloud platform that
are constantly creating and deleting
clusters so this helps to give us a
critical black box view into what a user
would see it's in order to gather this
data in every cloud location we have a
job running outside of GCP called the
monitoring server and this collects
metrics metadata and core component logs
from each master so our definition of
mass availability is based on cubes ETL
component statuses returning healthy for
every component and if availability is
down for a short period of time the
monitoring server will automatically
recreate the unavailable unhealthy
master VM and it can also resize the
master VM in order to handle higher
workloads and if these actions don't
work and the master continues to remain
under bay
and alert is sent to your friendly on
caller this can also happen if some
other metrics get into a bad state
according to some predefined conditions
such as at CD backups being too old or
master VM discs being too full and
depending on the severity of the
condition the alert can be either a
ticket or a page that requires an
immediate response and it might be
version specific location specific or
even cluster specific and we can also
get tickets from our frontline support
team if they're seeing urgent customer
issues and I think we're pretty lucky in
gke
that so many Googlers are contributors
to the open source project so when we do
see issues or bugs with an underlying
version of kubernetes we can pretty
easily get those fixes and so a common
workflow might be an on caller receives
an alert we would then check our
dashboards and metrics to see the vital
signs of the cluster look in the
playbook for mitigation and debugging
tips these might include some of the at
CD bugs then I described earlier and
then we typically use one of the
following common procedures to mitigate
against problems so rolling back or
rolling forward if it's a problem with
the gke control plane that's pretty
straightforward as we have full control
of those jobs if it's a problem with an
underlying kubernetes version it's a
little bit trickier we would need to cut
a release with a fix and upstream it
we can also upsize or upgrade the master
if it's a cluster specific issue
typically we'll try to give the master a
few more resources and in the case of
higher workloads that's pretty effective
sometimes we'll have to tweak the alert
if it's set to sensitively or if it
fired in a way that didn't make sense
and this is part of iterating on our
alerts to make sure that they're all
actionable and finally we do sometimes
have to resort to silencing alerts we
try to avoid this as much as possible
but sometimes
it's down to an issue that we can't take
direct action on for example if we need
to wait for the next open source release
or if it's an issue where the customer
has to go into the cloud console and and
fix the problem
so we've talked a little bit about the
routine alerts and routine mitigation
actions but sometimes a large outage
occurs something completely unexpected
and there's a large impact instant so
what do we do in those scenarios so in
sre we follow a mantra of coordinate
communicate and control with an
established protocol in a crisis so on
caller's are encouraged to pull in other
members of their team and get help
and define assigned defined roles so you
have an incident commander who is
managing and coordinating efforts an
Operations lead and a communications
lead so there are established
communications channels that identify
the impact and notify our customers you
may have seen some of these on our cloud
page there's also escalation paths to
other parts of of cloud and also our
developers who have their own on-call
rotations for various subsystems within
gke and kubernetes that they have more
expertise on and after the incident it's
really important that we write a
post-mortem and even more importantly we
learn from those action from the action
items from the post-mortem and execute
on them to make sure that the incident
is not repeated and sometimes we even
share some of these details with our
customers so the timeline of the instant
the root cause and the action items that
we're taking so that's what we're doing
on our side to improve the resilience of
the system to wrap up as potential
regional cluster users what can what can
you do to help improve the resilience of
your cluster and also help us not to get
paged so in the open-source version of
this talk and that I gave it cube con
we'd talk about
ensuring that your @cd backups are done
frequently and that you also test the
restore from backup procedure frequently
as well but as I mentioned before in gke
this happens automatically for you and
similarly if you're running your own
master I'd be advising that you upgrade
frequently and keep on top of the latest
security fixes but again this is taking
care of you taking care for you in our
managed kubernetes products however as a
gk user you still have full control over
the upgrade cycle of your nodes and we
strongly recommend that you enable node
Auto updates so we can keep it in sync
with the master version as well as node
auto repair for fully self-healing
cluster we also recommend that your
provisioning your project to have the
quota and capacity to handle these
multiple multi zonal workloads and
something you can do to help the
Carini's scheduler out is to provide
resource limits for your pods and make
allow to schedule those a little bit
more intelligently as an application
developer it's important that you're
aware of those high availability
scenarios high availability masters
regional masters do not make your
workloads high availability out of the
box spread your pods across multiple
zones and machines using pod anti
affinity and ensure that you're using
regional storage and data services so
you thank you all for joining us in this
talk and learning about gke an interest
of time Tina and I are going to have to
give up this room but we're going to be
available outside to answer any
questions you might have and otherwise
please enjoy the rest of the day thank
you
[Music]